bonjour mesdames et messieurs tels que
la dernière fois que vous adresser la
parole sur le sujet c'est bien sûr au
nom de la ministre de l'environnement
l'honorable leona aglukkaq que je vous
adresse la parole donc pour nom de la
ministre de l'environnement et ministre
responsable de l'agencé canadienne de
développement économique du nord et
ministre responsable du conseil de
l'arctique
elle a fait la déclaration suivante
concernant le projet l'intention de la
ville de montréal de divorce de déverser
8 milliards de litres d'eaux usées
brutes dans le fleuve sénat donc la
situation de la ministre le fleuve
saint-laurent est l'une des voies
navigables les plus importantes du
canada
il est l'habitat de plusieurs espèces de
baleines et de poissons il fournit de
l'eau potable à des millions de
canadiens en vertu de l'article 36
points 3 de la loi sur les pêches
il est interdit de rejeter une substance
nocive dans des eaux où vivent des
poissons ainsi il est crucial que en
tant que ministre de l'environnement je
fasse preuve de diligence raisonnable
pour veiller à ce que tout soit fait
pour protéger la vie aquatique dans le
fleuve sénat à ma demande
environnement canada a demandé plus de
renseignements à la ville de montréal
afin d'évaluer les éventuelles
répercussions de ces plans sur
l'environnent
mon ministère est si déterminé que les
répercussions environnementales du
déversement projeté serait assez grand
de plus la ville de morehead de montréal
n'a pas fait d'études sur les
répercussions possibles de ce
déversement de 8 milliards de litres
d'eau brute en particulier enfin les
données étant limitées environnement
canada ne peux pas confirmer si les eaux
usées brutes qui doivent être déversés
ont un degré de toxicité aiguë cela dit
la ville de montréal a indiqué que ce
projet particulièrement urgent et que
selon ces évaluations
il ne s'agit là que de la seule option
viable tenant compte de ces enjeux des
grandes préoccupations du public et de
la nécessité d'avoir en main une analyse
scientifique rigoureuse et complète de
ce projet j'ai chargé environnement
canada de demander à un expert
indépendant de procéder à un examen
scientifique de toutes les informations
liées à ce projet
cet examen qui sera appuyé par les
scientifiques du gouvernement du canada
ira puiser dans les renseignements
fournis par la ville
la province et d'autres experts
scientifiques et techniques vraiment
dans ce domaine afin d'analyser la
proposition actuelle ainsi que d'autres
options dont la ville dispose
l'objectif étant de trouver la meilleure
solution possible pour le fleuve seniors
en attendant que l'expert indépendant
termine son examen scientifique
je vais utiliser un arrêté d'urgence en
vertu de l'article 37 de la loi sur les
pêches afin de suspendre le projet
l'examen scientifique réalisée par un
tiers indépendant garantir la meilleure
protection possible aux fleuves sénat